hi I'm Christopher Hine and today we're
going to talk about the difference
between jiu-jitsu and Aikido so Jitsu
and Aikido have a very entangled past so
Aikido comes from jiu-jitsu more heyyo a
Shiba studied jiu-jitsu and and the
ideas of Aikido came from that but
Aikido became a different martial art
than jiu-jitsu and so today we're gonna
take Josh and Maia we're gonna have them
do a myriad of different practices live
practices so you guys can see what the
different difference between those two
are so in Aikido you have a goal that is
simply to not be dominated that's the
only goal of Aikido I don't I don't want
to throw anyone else or hurting a while
so do anything anyone else whereas in
shits if you have a very clear goal of I
do want to dominate someone else right
so I'm in contention with someone else
and the way I'm gonna stop that
contingent is to physically dominate
them both have their place so one's not
better than the other but they're two
totally different kinds of studies if
you are not very skilled and not very
physical then Aikido would probably be a
better way to go because you're not
going to physically dominate someone
who's greater than you however if you
have a chance then maybe jiu-jitsu is
the way to handle it right so there's
different ways that you want to approach
situations at different times and so
there's different martial arts for that
so a lot of times I think when jiu-jitsu
people look at Aikido they think Aikido
is trying to achieve the same goals as
jiu-jitsu does and so it's confusing to
look at and I think a lot of times
Aikido practice Aikido people see
jiu-jitsu and they kind of want to do
jiu-jitsu and so then that gets all
mixed up so we need to have a clear way
to look at the difference and so at
least with my approach to Aikido I'm
going to show the difference between
those two so we're gonna have Josh Amaya
do a modern style Jiu Jitsu grappling
that's gonna be on the ground then we're
gonna have him do some arm grappling
that would be a little more like
traditional Jiu Jitsu and then we're
gonna have a move into Aikido and you'll
be able to see in a live context how
each one of those is different I'm gonna
call Joshua my ad here we're gonna work
for you guys
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so this is a classic modern style
jiu-jitsu there's no weapon
they're just grappling if you're looking
at this you can see some pretty typical
stuff you would see in most jiu-jitsu
schools you would go look at right now
there is a high emphasis on head control
leg control and core control so you can
see they're really working each other's
legs and my is trying to work his legs
to pass josh trying to hold her in
there's a little bit of wrist control
going on there but not too much much
more elbow control and in core control
so I was trying to hold him Josh uses
that to sweep and again we're seeing
just body controls the main idea here
right so josh is trying to squish her
down as much as he can she's gonna use
that against em here in a second so
she's baiting him to go to one side and
then she's gonna hook in he put his leg
in there and which is exactly what she
wanted to trap the arm and she gets the
sweep there she's a tank top position
she's trying to pass we're gonna go
ahead and pause it right here okay so
you see basic stuff you see there in
classic jujitsu which is because there's
no weapon involved you can choose to go
either right or left you're free to go
either right to the right or the left
wrist control is not of great importance
because the arms aren't actually doing
all that much they can generally be
taken care of by pushing an elbow off or
or ducking around the arm so most of
what the arms are doing can be nullified
much more easy than wrist control so
most of the emphasis is going towards
legs clearing the legs trying to pass
those legs and core control and head
control so there was tons of that in
there and that's what you would see in
modern jujitsu is lots of those things
because there's no weapon to be involved
right so the arms are really not of that
great importance okay so now we're gonna
see a hybridizing between the two which
is you're gonna see a ground only game
which is more what modern jujitsu goes
towards now is is ground grappling
ground grappling is much more important
and modern jujitsu than it was in
traditional jujitsu so we're gonna see
that but at the same time we're gonna
introduce a weapon and so Maya has a
weapon tucked into her pants in the
front there
and she's been instructed to only draw
the knife when they go into the clinch
and also the second they go into the
clinch Josh could draw the knife as well
so so they're going to be grappling on
the ground only over this weapon that's
coming to play and so we're gonna see
even though this is really pushed
towards a lot of what modern jujitsu is
in the in the ground emphasis the heavy
ground ephesus we're gonna start to see
a change towards what more traditional
jujitsu looks like and we'll see some of
the kinds of things you see in Aikido
because of the weapons is in play so
let's watch this now okay so Maya is
already trying to get to that knife Josh
knew so he checked the hand and we have
classic top date or here's what we'd
call this an Aikido he drove her down
that opportunity just trying to crank it
out of her hand so he's trying to work
it's kind of a bad camera angle to see
he's still trying to clear those legs
because they're on the ground it's got
to get over those legs he and one hand
and control that weapon he felt like he
could and he used that to pass so we got
a nice pass there
Cates trying to get around my is
wrapping her legs right back around and
he stacked her up a little bit there but
notice how heavy the emphasis is on
wrist control heavy heavy heavy heavy
wrist control this is like you would see
in Aikido or more importantly like you
would see in traditional jujitsu so the
the wrist control stuff that we have an
Aikido comes from traditional jujitsu so
that's why there's all this wrist
control because there's a weapon in play
if they were to ignore those and be no
good Josh had to fall back there tries
to go into an armbar is kicking her arm
free he's got the knife now and he's
going to work with that knife and that's
time for those guys okay so there we can
see a practice that is is kind of in
between the modern world of jiu-jitsu
and the classic world of jutsu because
we're seeing the emphasis on heavy
groundwork and as some of the techniques
you would see in modern jiu-jitsu for
sure and then at the same time we're
seeing some traditional techniques start
to appear right so in that if you saw
there was there's an EQ involved there's
several different little things came out
and lots of the classic holds that you
see in Aikido which is katate dori okay
taurima rotate or real did all those
wrist holds were constantly happening in
that and the reason is because there's a
weapon in place so that's why Aikido has
that emphasis on risk control is big
as traditional jiu-jitsu also had an
emphasis in risk control for some of the
stuff okay so now we stood these guys up
so now we're getting a little more into
what a true traditional jiu-jitsu
practice would be so the last one is
kind of hybridizing between what you see
in a lot of modern jiu-jitsu and what
you see in traditional jiu-jitsu this is
going to be a lot more like traditional
jutsu now so they're standing up Maya
has the knife the knife's already out so
the knife's already in play she can draw
it and use the knife as soon as she
wants
but her emphasis is jujitsu right so she
wants to get Josh and stab Josh that's
her goal so she's got the knife out but
she wants to get a hold of that guy hold
him down and stab him as much as she can
and Josh of course would like to get the
knife away from her and then do the same
thing to her if he if he gets the knife
he's gonna hold her down and stab her so
this is Jiu Jitsu right the idea is to
dominate so let's go ahead and push play
on this okay so my got a cut in there
Josh kind of blocked that out and he's
put it up tight got a nice outside leg
sweep he's trying to move around to the
outside
mais using her legs to kind of frame up
she's trying to get that weapon freeze
mostly what she's trying to do in this
position right now
and Josh managed to get it right so he
did a quick Miki over there
switched over okay now Josh doesn't want
to get away he wants to work her right
so he's working around the outside and
trying to stab her she kind of tied him
up in that once she got the weapon hand
Josh went to a position trying to
isolate and get that weapon free so
right now josh is just trying to get
that weapon freeze cranking around the
top as much as he can she's holding him
he's really trying to work that the
weapon hand out so he's finding some way
to frame mais giving him a good time
here
he's now isolated that knife off to the
side there he's gonna try and work it
out so again this is a lot like modern
Jiu Jitsu a lot of ground stuff kam eyes
trying to stand and Josh is sticking
right with her just she's gonna fall
back here in a second so he's trying to
fall to a rear-naked but notice he had
to keep his hand on that knife he
couldn't just go deposit he couldn't
just go into that rear-naked like you
would in modern jujitsu because he had
to keep the knife in check right so
that's a that's an important difference
between learning to grapple armed and
learned grandpa unarmed if you learn to
grapple unarmed it's really confusing a
lot of times when there's a weapon in
play because what you're trained to do
how you're trained to move
won't account for the weapon because
you're not used to dealing with a weapon
and so there's a lot of sacrifices you
have to make when you start grappling
with a weapon so you know the beginning
of that standard started out exactly
like traditional Jitsu and went to the
ground and it's not the traditional
Jitsu didn't have ground emphasis but
the main emphasis was was standing stuff
okay so now we're gonna see Aikido
scenario so Maya again has the knife
Maya's told to treat Josh in an Aikido
fashion so now she's going to try to use
Aikido to thwart Josh's attempt to use
jiu-jitsu so josh is still using
jiu-jitsu essentially right so it's
gonna be it's gonna look much more like
traditional Jiu Jitsu now and the reason
for that being that and you know that
that's a small distinction sometimes but
the reason for that being he's going to
be trying a lot of stand-up things
because there's a weapon in play and
we'll see that here in a second but
Josh's goal is to dominate mine his
goals to take her down in to dominate
her Maya's job is to stay away from Josh
not do anything to him if she doesn't
need to but use the weapon of course if
she if she needs to or has the
opportunity to but her main goal is just
to stay away from Josh now we're gonna
see how this exchange between these two
people plays out a little different so
my is it distance right now she's gonna
try and keep that when you're play case
trying to keep it showing that knife
trying to keep him away Josh goes in
defensive position Maya gets pushed
around now josh is just driving her as
hard as he can right now so all he's
trying to do is knock her down that's it
and my is turning with it blending with
it moving with it staying staying saying
Josh Nell has a my rope they Dory okay
so he's coming he tries to silent akkad
doesn't work Maya pulls him around and
just trying to like sweep my stepping
out of it mice trying to clear out now
she can't she's Aniki oh there she gets
free and again she's trying to make
distance so she doesn't want to get Josh
she wants to stay away she's framing out
with sungkoo sabaki josh pushed in hard
she got kite to nage there josh is
coming around mice trying to frame at
Josh got her leg that time brings her
down there on the ground
my is now using the knife to strike Josh
Josh used his hands to come up so means
he let go over that gave John a my the
opportunity to get up again so no my
eyes back up moving out to the outside
josh is trying to stalk her just trying
to put her in a corner my sting out of
those corners the best she can
mice framing son Cacoo sabaki again and
again not really kite to Naga there but
and that's the end of the tape alright
guys so that is basic comparison at the
the
school between the different systems and
looking at how jujitsu and Aikido are
just inherently different the idea in
Aikido is to always get away whereas the
Aikido the idea in jujitsu is to
dominate and that might not seem like a
big deal it might kind of seem like well
why not just study jiu-jitsu and then
use that to get away the problem with
that is your training a mentality that
constantly wants to put you back into a
bad situation right so you know if
you're not the dominant factor and you
can't dominate in a situation the best
thing for you to do is get out of that
situation and that's what Aikido always
emphasizes is making distance and
getting out of that situation whereas
jiu-jitsu is taking an advantage of
opportunities to attack and while
sometimes that might pay off for you if
the odds are stacked greatly against you
then it's probably not going to be the
best idea for you to have so there you
can see kind of a good example of two
the same exact two people both trained
quite a lot in Aikido with some training
in jiu-jitsu and you can kind of see how
the differences between those two people
doing different situations you know they
both done a lot of armed grappling so
traditional jutsu quite a bit modern
jiu-jitsu a fair amount but but not all
that much you know so they're not
stellar modern jiu-jitsu practitioners
but you can see the idea of how those
two interact with each other in a modern
jujitsu situation how they interact with
each other in a hybridized situation
between modern jiu-jitsu and traditional
jiu-jitsu and a much more traditional
jiu-jitsu sense and then in an Aikido
sense ins you can kind of get an idea by
looking at those four videos what the
real difference is between Aikido and
jiu-jitsu and you can kind of get an
idea of what the difference is between
modern jiu-jitsu and traditional
jiu-jitsu so I'm Christopher Hine thanks
a lot for guys for watching we'll see
you next time
you
[Music]